Okay. Let's talk today about Iran, Venezuela,
and Syria and I mentioned yesterday that I
want to discuss the, the Putin
angle on the latest Iran stuff, but I also
want to talk about it in the larger context
and there's a really good post about this
on our sub Reddit, David pakman.com/reddit
which outlines sort of the underlying idea
that I want to present to you here. And it's
something I've been thinking about a thought
about it over the weekend as the Iran News
was breaking and I've continued thinking about
it and the idea is that in the end, Donald
Trump may be destined to stay out of Iran
and stay out of Venezuela and ultimately stay
out of Syria in any serious way because staying
out of those three countries shares a common
thread, which is that it's in Vladimir Putin's
and Russia's interests for the United States
to stay out of those three countries. Now
I, I, I know, I know that I have to issue
this disclaimer. I hope we can be mature here.
Okay. This is not, Putin is literally telling
Trump what to do, although who knows what
they've talked about in private. We actually
don't know, but it's the trend once again,
that in the end when the rubber meets the
road, Trump ends up taking the path that is
in Russia's interests and this is not about
collusion or Trump criminality or anything
like that. It's about geopolitical realities.
It's about the realities of the dynamics that
are forming. As I've talked to you about many
times now among the three major super powers
right now, the United States, China and Russia
in a way that is not very good for the United
States under Donald Trump, Iran, Venezuela,
and Syria are three allies of Russia and the
trend in Donald Trump's presidency, it's not
100% but it's a high percentage, is that in
the end, rhetoric aside, Trump ends up acting
in a way that protects, or does it go against
or threaten Russia's interests and let's go
through them one by one here, Trump does a
big boy and he attacks Syria, except he attacked
an empty runway at an airport after telling
Russia that he was going to do it and it was
back up and running within a couple of days,
if not more like ours.
And so for all of the tough talk, Trump does
effectively nothing. Now this doesn't mean
I want Trump intervening in Syria. What we're
doing here is an analysis of how Trump's actions
relate to Russia's interests. Not me saying
I want Trump to take a B or c action. That's
Syria, Venezuela, number two. In the winter.
As I told you last week, Donald Trump was
looking very hard at going into Venezuela,
forcing regime change. To be clear, I don't
want him to do that. I'm glad that Donald
Trump didn't do that. Don't email me saying,
I want Trump to intervene in, in Venezuela
because I don't. But last week I told you
that there are some new reports from inside
sources would say that Donald Trump simply
got bored and sort of lost patience with the
complexity of the entire Venezuela thing,
which is totally believable. But once again,
in the end, it favors Vladimir Putin.
Putin and the Chavez Maduro regime are tight.
We know that much of the change in Donald
Trump's focus on Venezuela happened after
a phone call with Vladimir Putin in early
May. And once again, in the end, Donald Trump
takes the path that, at least in the immediate,
is the one that protects Russia's interests,
uh, and favors favors Vladimir Putin. And
then number three, we now have Iran. Yes,
the bluster against Iran, the threats, the
sanctions and threats of sanctions backing
out of the Iran deal. The entire thing we
told you about yesterday, including Donald
Trump authorizing a strike against Iran over
the weekend, but then calling it off says
it was over civilian casualty estimates, which
may be true, but once again, Trump, despite
the domineering rhetoric ends up taking the
action or more accurately not taking the action
that favors Vladimir Putin and his in Russia's
interests. So again, please don't make this
out to be me saying anything other than what
I'm actually saying.
I am not saying Trump is personally colluding
with Putin on these three foreign policy situations.
I'm not alleging to a legend or pointing to
some kind of conspiracy. I'm pointing out
that in the end, Donald Trump is taking the
paths here that Putin would want him to take.
If you're concerned with what's in the United
States best interests, then you have to be
concerned about the u s increasingly being
in a weak position relative to the two to
the two other major super powers, Russia and
China, who has, I've told you before, are
increasingly working together at the disadvantage
of and exclusion of the United States. Now.
Maybe you don't care about that. I mean, there
are people who, even though they might live
in the United States as most, but not all
of our audience does, who don't care if the
United States is better or worse position
than they say, we're all humans.
I don't care about country borders and I don't
care as long as we raise the overall wellbeing.
That's my concern. I don't care what happens
to the United States. Many of us, even on
the left, who live in the United States are
invested in the United States being a good
place to live in a place that has a good standard
of living in the relationships we would like
to see with other countries. And so we do
care about this. So please don't start with
the, you know, I must be a warmonger stuff
because I'm criticizing Trump for not going
into Iran, Syria or Venezuela. I want Bashar
Al Assad out for the sake of the Syrian people,
but not at the hands of the United States.
I think the United States needs to stay totally
out of Venezuela. I do not want Donald Trump
starting a war with Iran. This is not about
me personally.
These are radic maneuvers by Trump are odd
baiting Iran into action, pulling the US out
of the Iran deal, getting the opportunity
to keep escalating. And then now last minute
bailing on the escalation. If a Democratic
president had done this, it would be every
low rent rightwing analyst on Fox News 24
seven talking about how weak Obama or Hillary
or whoever was by virtue of taking the action
that Donald Trump has taken. So my concern
is the underlying geopolitical concerns that
exist here. And number two, whether Donald
Trump is actually in the end making the decisions
that even he believes are in the best interest
of the United States. I know that I wouldn't
agree with his conclusions about what's best
for the United States, but at least I would
like to believe that in good faith, that's
what his decisions are informed by. Even if
I would disagree with the conclusions, it's
not clear that that's going on based on how
at least these three situations are playing
out in the end.
Let me know. You're thinking about this and
if you're going to do the conspiratorial,
you know, uh, allegations to don't even bother.
I'm not going to respond. I'm not going to
engage. But if you have a serious thought
about what I've laid out here, I actually
do want to hear from you.